et on continue de parler de la situation
en birmanie avec notre invité les temps
direct avec nous pierre picard et légers
au politologue et spécialiste de la
suite bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on a entendu
le chef de l'armée qui promet des
élections multipartites et démocratiques
d'ici de jean est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle ou est-ce que c'est dans trop
longtemps enfin comment doit-on
accueillir cette annonce alors
évidemment c'est toujours une bonne
nouvelle d'avoir des annonces je dirais
qu'ils promettent la démocratie alors
que la birmanie était un petit peu dans
le chaos depuis plus de six mois depuis
que la junte militaire a renversé le
régime démocratiquement élu et là on
aime situation qui est comme dans
d'autres pays mais qui est encore plus
dramatique puisque se rajoute aux effets
économiques désastreux de ce changement
de pouvoir brutal
une situation endémique et une situation
économique
ultime et amal l'enfant d'un mode laisse
donc on a simplement eu comme enjeu
aujourd'hui de remettre en place je
dirais une politique sanitaire efficace
pour la birmanie et en fit effectivement
de fiction démocratique pour retrouver
une stabilité alors que la birmanie
était aux normes on pensait qu'elle
était à nouveau sur les rails et bien
bon payer ce dérapage et et on peut
penser que la junte militaire est un
petit peu sous la pression
internationale est également sous la
pression de la population est
effectivement aujourd'hui je crois
qu'elle n'aurait guère de choix que de
si longues d'enfoncer le pays dans une
situation encore plus dramatique
donc oui il faut il faut espérer que
cette promesse verticaliser et le plus
rapidement possible avec l'aide
peut-être d'autres pays d'asie ou
internationaux alors des élections
multipartites en quelles sont donc les
partis qui pourraient se présenter à ces
élections
et y at-il eu des personnalités
peut-être qu'ils ont émergé depuis ces
six mois actuellement une chef de
l'opposition qui avait été arrêté il y a
6 mois et apparaît
type le firmament appareils comme étant
en position j'irai de force pour
remporter les élections parce qu'elle
est populaire
certainement que c'est le candidat qui
va représenter le plus de stabilité et
de sécurité c'est qu'ils aient le désir
des birmans qui va pourrait l'emporter
mais l'opposition à la junte militaire
est également très divisée comme
d'autres d'autres partis avec de
multiples partenaires
donc on peut imaginer que le résultat
des élections seraient favorables à
l'ancien chef du gouvernement
puisqu'elle était déjà élu en place et
qu'elle connaît les rênes du pouvoir en
savant travers quand ça en voile
pourrait faire un retour en politique
d'ici 20 ans un retour en politique bien
évidemment cela dépend d'une part
évidemment des électeurs birman si nous
avons des élections en birmanie
et puis bien évidemment eu de la chef de
l'opposition helle même alors le savez
l'armée s'est également dit prêt à
travailler avec à l'envoyé spécial que
va nommer la zenn quel est justement la
marge de manoeuvre de cette institution
aujourd'hui dans cette mondialisation
que le tier mise à mal par la pandémie
du de la copie des 19 la junte militaire
ne peut pas faire autrement
elle ne veut pas aller se dire et au
delà de l' isolement complet du pays de
la suite de la fermeture des frontières
de l'art et des voyages d'une situation
sanitaire catastrophique également de
d'une situation économique et sociale
qui est catastrophique avec des millions
et des millions de chômeurs
donc on a comme priorité y compris pour
la junte militaire y compris pour ses
intérêts militaires économiques et
financiers l'intérêt aujourd'hui de
collaborer avec l'az et âme avec l'onu
et l'ensemble des gir et des
organisations internationales je crois
qu'elle n'a pas le choix
1 - d'enfoncer le pays tant venus
dictature sanglante et est affreuse il
quel rôle peut-on attribuer à la
jeunesse berman qui participent
on l'a vu dans le sujet un massivement
à la révolte je parle de la génération
des moins de 25 ans oui alors votre
reportage était particulièrement
intéressant parce que on voit que dans
d'autres pays que c'est cette jeunesse
qui globalement n'a pas peur en tout cas
qui est très dynamique et qui expriment
eux d'une façon parfois naïve parfois
innocente en tout cas ce sera le bol et
puis ce désir finalement de de liberté
et de renouveau auquel aspire l'ensemble
du peuple birman mais rappelons le
l'ensemble de la majorité bien mal
aujourd'hui est relativement sage et
attend une seule chose
majoritairement c'est ce qui a changé la
donne au niveau de ce changement de
pouvoir à savoir une situation sanitaire
qui serait je dirais acceptable ou
rétablie notamment le fait de pouvoir
vacciner les birmans de recevoir des
accents ce qui pose problème
actuellement en birmanie donc problème
numéro un
rétablir une situation sanitaire a créé
tard et puis favorable pour ces pays
épisode numéro 2 faire en sorte que on
remettre le pays sur les rails
démocratie en tout cas de la démocratie
birmane et non pas en dehors du virement
remis avec l'ensemble du peuple birman
est ensuite renoncé dans la stabilité
une économie favorable pour les pires
mans et puis également tous tuez votre
peuple qui qui travaillent ou qui
échangent avec pierre picard merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes géo politologue
et spécialiste de l'asie ce mercier